hi Russell fault smith i'm CTO and AI
biologist maslow AI and what i'm talking
about today is the possibilities of
general artificial intelligence in
particular an artistic process and what
i call shared consequences so coming to
agreement between different beings on
what we want to do what we want to be
and what we consider the consequences
I'm Russ I'm CTO of a company called
Maslow which takes a the wolfram and the
nks stuff very seriously
I was an employee at WolframAlpha worked
with my buddy Schaller here and the
whole Wolfram Alpha Team getting that
out the door 10 years ago I can't
believe it's been 10 years since I've
been in Champaign actually what I
decided after doing lots of other things
that I would continue taking the ideas
seriously and so I've helped create a
company that literally is trying to
create computational beings which may
sound weird and I hope it sounds weird
because weird is good and so I'm going
to give a little bit of an interactive
talk about what I think that means and
what I think we can do and what
possibilities are I want to encourage
you everything I do is interactive
theatrical playful all these QR codes in
the talk are active and they go to lots
of other things and lead lead to many
places so I highly encourage everybody
to follow go where you want to go
everybody has a computer everybody has
phone so do whatever you want
even if you don't want to listen to me
but you want to read stuff go do it a
little bit about me I may occasionally
random event punctuated by things that I
think have meaning you can read this
lots of things are going on in my life
have gone on lots of things are going on
in your life we're all here for
different reasons
some are known to us some are not known
to us we're computing is where society
is where technology is we have lots of
narratives about it but I don't know if
any of us are confident in that those
narratives are true and it may not
necessarily be important that they're
true it may just be important that we
have narratives and they allow us to
keep trying things so take this idea
that I said that I take these things
very seriously
I started getting
in KS and computationally inspired
tattoos
invisible parts of my body to remind
myself to keep on computing and I mean
that not just in a jokey way but if you
if you if you were at the keynote last
night and I think near the end of
Stevens marathon I thought it was I
always I think he gets to the really
juicy stuff at the end when you're out
of steam and this idea that he and I
certainly him devoted to a to this idea
that we need to keep giving people more
capabilities and so I'm so fascinated by
how he how devoted he and the company
and this community is to just continuing
to try to build stuff because when you
think about all the things he talked
about last night
I sit there and I kind of go what the
hell is everybody doing we don't need
all this stuff but in a way that's
what's so cool about it it just gives us
more possibility and more things to play
with and I think that's the only
justification we actually need because
again if you go back to your own life
story and you think about how you got
here
it probably wasn't an obvious easy thing
the tools that you had at the time we're
different than the ones that you have
now and the idea that we have all of
these computational capabilities now to
help us navigate our lives as we're
writing the story of our lives I think
is pretty cool and I think Stephens
right and what he said that we are at at
what I what feels like to me to that
we're at this pretty interesting point
where these capabilities are coming
online so rapidly we haven't figured out
how to integrate them yet which is
something I am devoted to so I'm I make
a big claim and again I'm kind of gonna
jump around here but it comes together I
make a big claim about what general
artificial intelligence is because I
think the words general artificial
intelligence are kind of silly words in
a way which isn't to negate them but the
idea that that we're going to go chase
the dream
of general artificial intelligence when
I don't think we have a good definition
of intelligence itself and that's not to
say we shouldn't figure out that out or
take it seriously and not think that
humans are intelligent or something like
that but it's more the point that we
should keep defining what that is which
is what I think computational
intelligence is it gives us a reframing
of what we might be doing and what the
universe and beings in the universe
might be doing as such why I go to an
artistic idea of this is I with the
things you see on the screen some of you
how many people are familiar with the
three things you see on the screen cool
so so generally these are these are
artifacts popular artifacts of art
throughout time we have a famous scene
from Macbeth which is the where I get
the title of my talk the famous opening
where the three witches visit Macbeth
and then he he starts to realize that
this this idea in his mind of being King
and all these things are gonna happen
maybe more real than the things that are
actually happening and it takes on this
life of his own right this very famous
scene it ties to my idea of what
computational intelligence is which is
this idea to imagine a possibility space
to literally generate possibilities the
the middle image is the the famous cave
paintings from from the caves in France
fascinating paintings should definitely
look them up because you just think
about 40,000 years ago humans like us
were in caves doing these wonderful
things they think they were actually
animating them using fire and the way
that the light would flicker and then
the famous this is not a pipe the real
title of painting is the treachery of
images I find great inspiration in this
image and all of them agree to work
because they think he was a pretty
serious thinker about things and
ontology of things and what what things
might actually be and this is important
because when I talk about general
artificial intelligence and I talk about
art I can guarantee you that we have yet
to make a machine no matter how powerful
or whatever our network of machines the
supercomputers we don't even have a way
of processing what those three images
are like nothing we can we could talk
about them as images we can compute on
them we can do all sorts of things but
in no sense will the computer ever get
back to you and say this is what this is
and to me that's really really important
because when you think about what you're
actually doing on your computer in what
sense when you're when you're typing and
you're writing a program in what sense
can you claim you understand what that
program is you get the essence of that
program and again go back to Stephens
talk last night and you think about all
the things that he was doing and all the
weird tentacles that went off and did
stuff in what sense could we we define
and reduce down Stephens talk into a
program you can't it was an artistic
performance he even uses the word art
when he talks a lot right it's just this
is a the art of demoing he likes to say
I think and it's true because he's he's
sort of being performative and again I
don't mean that in a in a negative way
it's actually this is important because
what he's trying to do
what I'm trying to do is generate a
shared imagination he's trying to get us
all to like think to figure out like
literally just go compute and see what
these tools can do for us
we're not trying to reduce down and say
this is the only way that you can
compute this is the only way that you
can think about these things this is the
only space for intelligent things this
is the only possibility of these tools
quite the opposite so I get to put all
that together and I get to a statement I
don't think anybody here is doing
programming I don't think we program
computers I think we expressed to that
we we create a shared language with them
I think Wolfram language is a very
interesting
this is what sort of drew drew me to it
in my early career was it was a very
expressive language it allowed me to
express ideas and now literally in
everything that you do whether it's art
or business random projects stuff with
the school that I created
I am constantly using Wolfram language
to compute things and just show and
communicate communicate the ideas to the
computer communicate the ideas to to
kids or to business people obviously
using Wolfram language to communicate to
you
so let's dial it back we kind of went
way forward let's dial it back
so it's interesting because when we talk
about the power of all that these
computers can do and we really want to
like let's just compute and go do stuff
it's almost like a universal thing that
that in order to go compute humans
demand that other humans stand up in
front of them and and give them ideas on
what to compute and I always like to
think like why is that so powerful why
is it so powerful that I stand up or
Steven or somebody stands up in front or
you get a demo from someone or whatever
we just get a community community like
this together why is it so powerful why
do we need that as humans
if these computers can actually do all
the things that we claim they can do
there's something that's happening in
this modality between people that is
really critical that if you just stare
at an inert computer is it really going
to do anything are you gonna feel like
it's doing something you're gonna
believe they can do something you're
gonna entrust it to do something there's
something about human to human
interaction that I think is critical so
second thing let's let's get a little
weirder here dogs I like to talk about
dogs I love dogs had dogs growing up and
when we talk about ideas of computation
and intelligence and mathematics and
fundamental theories of physics and you
know pick whatever technical topic you
want to you want to talk about
I like to think about what dogs think
about that what is the experience of a
dog and why why do we have no problem
believing that a dog is intelligent
sentient navigating the world has
perceptive abilities and yet we haven't
quite figured out how to talk about
computers like that and it's like okay
well how are you acquitting these things
because again go back to that statement
where I said we are not programming
computers we're actually expressing I
think this reframing is important we
have no problem framing a dog is having
a alternative intelligence to human
intelligence they don't speak our
language I think it's fair to assume
that none of us think that dogs have a
mathematical theory of the universe and
yet they have no problem navigating the
world they have no problem computing
they have no problem expressing
themselves we have no problem learning
how they express themselves
it is a coevolution of that expression
and just just to make the point this
seems to be a good relationship and a
coevolution because dog population it's
up to a billion worldwide Freddie's
crazy to think for every every seven
people we have a dog so this this
coevolution is quite effective so again
go down a level why am I saying all this
reframe it there is no base truth or
root of reality there is well I think
Steven is gonna make interesting
progress and whoever is helping them on
a fundamental theory of physics the
question I would ask is what will that
get us well when we have that theory
what are we gonna do we're gonna compute
we're gonna figure out what it means
we're gonna go we're gonna go do stuff
with it because it note whatever this
fundamental theory might be whatever AI
might be it's not like that's the end
and the universe collapses it's not like
if we invent general artificial
intelligence this is gonna think itself
out of existence it's gonna make more
stuff it's gonna actually paint pictures
of a pipe and say this is not a pipe
right so my point tie it to this thing
that there is no basis of truth or and
I'm not saying things aren't true
because 2+2 does in fact equal 4 I'm
just saying there's no there is no
directionality to which truth is more
fundamental that's really important when
you talk about art when you talk about
computational thinking when you talk
about being when you talk about who we
might be and what we want to become when
you talk about purpose you you don't
define it it's not as useful to define
it in a direction instead it's like
things can be meaningful things can be
purposeful but not tied to some anchor
kind of thing so I'm gonna let because I
want to keep moving along here but I'm
building up a case that reframing this
all is very important these QR codes I
encourage you to visit them on your own
I use the QR codes I'm sort of abusing
them to to make a point that what hell
is a QR code we just sort of decided
this configuration of pixels can
represent anything we want it to I don't
know if anybody studied the encoding
algorithms of QR codes they're quite
fascinating how weird it's it's been in
what they actually use for but these QR
codes remind me a lot of the elementary
cellar automata and that it's like in
some sense we're just interpreting grids
of pixels and we sort of decide what we
want to talk about when we talk about
does in what sense are these pixels not
just QR codes and there's something else
and they're bits in the system they're
they're artworks they're there the links
behind the things and it's like well why
is that important to what you're saying
I go how is a computer
how would intelligence think about QR
codes what do you think about you are
codes what actually are they oh well
they're QR codes there is no basis track
with me there's no basis there's no
route that a QR code is tied to it's all
those things that I talked about
it is pixels it is an image on a screen
it is encoding something else it does
spin off in lots of
actions if you do change one bit it is
no longer a QR code okay the way I like
to tie these things together in a
productive way is if if there were a way
to make sense of all these things I'm
sort of making nonsense of it's what I
call computational adjacency so I take
Stephens idea of computational
irreducibility take it seriously that
that there are just lots of uncomputable
things and the things that are there
universally computable can compute
others all the other things and it's
like it just never ends and like we're
never going to reduce it into like okay
we figured it out the universe is now
done but we can use that idea and this
other idea of computational adjacency to
order things in the world and what I
mean by that is we tend to relate to
things in the world by how similar in
scope their computations are go back to
the dog example which is I think we
relate very reliably to dogs because
they inhabit the same computational
space as humans the same temperature
gradients affect them the same sleep
cycles affect them the same facial
expressions the same relatively the same
vision and hearing signal spaces affect
them in similar ways we very much are
computing in similar ways we have
adjacency okay get to my next bullet
point to really pound at home this idea
that humans are the pinnacle of
intelligence and that our aim ought to
be to mimic human behavior doing very
trivial things like searching for memes
should indicate that it's a counterpoint
to maybe intelligence also human
intelligence has strange side effects
that maybe we wouldn't want to mimic in
our computers or maybe we would maybe a
sign of general artificial intelligences
Computers generate memes they find funny
dogs are not programmed they are shaped
so if you've never seen this video I
encourage you to watch it this is a 20
minute history of the world is hilarious
video but it is a
amazing thing and again if you fed it
into a computer you it is interesting to
see what it comes back with it cannot
make sense of this 20 minute history of
the world but you can I I am trying to
figure out how do we give a computer the
ability to make sense of this 20 minute
video definitely pull it up on your
phone if you can and to give you a sense
and again I pull it up in this thing of
just how how crazy it is to think about
reducing anything into something that we
can effectively say we've got it figured
out we have the definition we're good we
don't need to think about it anymore I
did some calculations to kind of figure
out right now on planet earth with a
three point five trillion fish the 24
quintillion microbes these are all
estimates the eight billion humans the 1
billion dogs pick all the insects I mean
you have so many creatures around here
right now all genetic experiments all
behavioral things going on doing all
sorts of crazy things as far as I can
estimate you have that really big number
of computations going on in the world
right now and yet so much of the aim of
artificial intelligence and in in the
industries that I tend to travel in is
is trying to reduce all that trying to
trying to claim that at some point
there's gonna be superhuman intelligence
to make sense of that it's just not a
believable claim yet I am claiming that
we still can have general artificial
intelligence it just won't be something
that reduces it generates okay people
are not programmed you see where I'm
going the theme here it should be clear
they're shaped we generate we generate
relationships between each other dogs
people computers people computers -
computers so this talk that I gave or
that I'm giving and about to run out of
time on I actually generated three other
talks in the process over the last month
of making this talk I'm not going to
give these talks right now these are fun
talks the middle one was it will
probably be a particular interest
people who wanted to be looking at code
and have me demo things there's plenty
of code there where I build up the
definition of a circle and then
demonstrate that machine learning our
current machine learning methods cannot
actually learn what a circle is
it's like why is that just ask yourself
what is a circle it's purely a
definitional thing there's nothing to be
learned there there's no if you feed a
computer images of a circle you're not
feeding it a circle you're feeding it a
reduced version of a circle if you feed
it a definition of a circle what have
you fed it you can't say it learned it
you gave it the definition so literally
I use all these fun machine learning
things to generate shapes and and run
them through every every Wolfram
technology I can to see if this machine
that I literally gave the definition of
a circle to can it ever resolved itself
into understanding what a circle is it
can't it's purely a definitional thing
that we're doing I could be wrong I'd be
curious if anybody goes and reads this
and plays with the code to see what
happens in the third thing I go ahead
and again I'm going to encourage you to
go get the notebook it's it's I'd put it
public on the cloud I literally play
with the Magritte image this is not a
pipe and just keep recursing on the
theme of this is not a pipe ultimately
letting the computer turn it into a song
a generative song about this is not a
pipe again using all sorts of Wolfram
technology to do it
and again only so it's like I don't
believe you can get to the truth of the
matter
you can only generate with it and the
more powerful something is the more
generative will be the universe is not
programmed I know that that many of us I
certainly have I fall into it probably
every other day I'm like we might be
living in a simulation oh my god
we're living in a simulation and he just
if that simulation is true if we
actually are in a simulation I don't
think it's because something from the
outside programmed it it's because its
generative reframe how we do computing
this is the way I'm trying to give us a
new way of thinking about computer
rather than finding problems to solve
let's just keep inventing new problems
let's just keep using these tools to
the universe so what are the
consequences of this what are our shared
consequences now what happens next I
have I'll give you what I propose as a
definition of time time is the
computational distance or difference
between one set of marks and another set
of marks the time between any of us in
this room is how long how much work
would we have to do to come to
understand each other to Co Express so
when you sit down at your computer and
you start typing away play with this
idea and think about which which
programs can actually map to other
programs that's the time that's the why
do I say time in response to
consequences because the amount of
consequences that you have to trade the
inputs and outputs between systems
between dogs and people between
computers and people between computers
and computer it's time its consequences
of poking and perturbing each other that
we experience that's what's actually
flowing is this computational difference
and we try and we're trying to come
closer together on this and amusingly
this is why I love doing it whoever
somebody posted this on the this
codebase on the Wolfram community I love
doing these cinnamon networks they're
just so fun to play with this and why do
I like this because these these this and
that have no they don't they don't
return anything
these are determiners they don't have
synonyms they just are what they are
time is in the middle of them taking
this to that and when I plot the network
of time I'm so amused by this these are
all the different words that mean
different things to time and yet it
looks like a clock it looks like a happy
face anybody else think it looks like a
happy face right what think about
everything I just said this is what
we're doing as humans we are computing
on so many levels of relating things we
understand that you almost can't help
but see that as a face and a happy face
and when I did that and I typed into the
computer I literally was like that's how
I'm ending this present
because that's hilarious it's like why
make that decision there's no
mathematical basis for that decision
other than we like smiling faces so my
pitch to you if it's a pitch is just to
keep computing with each other don't do
this in isolation I've created a company
that takes these ideas very seriously
and I'm literally trying to give tools
to the world to help more people express
themselves
I want to make computers expressible
which is why before you got in here and
I don't even care that this stuff stops
I literally just let computers run we
have a cloud set up where we just signal
process we take things in it paints it
does nothing but paint what signals we
send it so even when I'm here I record
things and I just let everything compute
and cross over because I just believe
the interesting stuff emerges from that
I think this proves in a roundabout way
the theorem you were all coming to see
proved the Infinite Monkey theorem if
you let an infinite number of monkeys
access to an infinite number of
typewriters they will in fact produce
the works of Shakespeare because they
already did so to me the aim shouldn't
be can we produce the works of
Shakespeare yet it's what else can we
produce what's the next Shakespeare we
shouldn't be tying our computational
intelligence to the things that have
already been done we should be creating
new things and in case I'll fold and
I'll kind of be a hypocrite on that
because the the rule 30 problem that
that Stephen is asking people to go
solve for him already been solved who's
read this short story the library Babel
there's a wonderful website you can go
to it you'll see you'll find the problem
statement and if you look hard enough
you'll find the solution to the rule 30
problems in the library of Babel I
encourage you if you never read the read
the short story read it and if you've
never played this to this website go
throw any of your Wolfram code into it
you'll find the your all your programs
are already
the library of Babel it's just a search
through possibility so if you're now
wondering who the hell I am I'm an
artist
I love Wolfram things I'm an educator
I'm a coder I'm a painter I'm a person
I'm a computational being that's my talk
thank you guys
[Applause]